HERE'S A FUN GAME: Count how many times I
say BOOBS in the next 2 minutes!
Hey everyone, Laci Green here for DNews.
It's time for a heart to heart.
There are a lot of things that make it hard
to exercise, and something that's definitely
on that list?
BOOOOOBS.
Oh yeah.
I'm no stranger to the boob struggle, it's
a real life issue.
Recently, a study published in the Journal
of Physical Activity and Health finds that
I am by NO MEANS alone.
In fact, boobs are a barrier to exercise for
nearly 1 in 5 women, or 17%.
They also found that women with boobs of all
sizes report this problem.
It's the first study to examine the unique
role that boobs play in women's participation
in sports.
Boobs were the 4th most common barrier cited.
#1 is a lack of energy, #2 is time constraints,
and #3 is health limitations.
The main complaints were that they weren't
able to find a proper sports bra and that
they felt embarrassed.
Which actually really surprises me - I would
have thought it would have been ACHEY, SHARP,
AGONIZING PAIN.....but maybe that's what they
mean by "can't find a proper sports bra".
Bra fit is a biggie - without a good sports
bra, high impact exercise is ALL KINDS of
uncomfortable.
A poorly fitted bra is one that allows excess
tension on the Coopers Ligaments, which stretches
and strains your breast's natural support
system.
This pulling results in both immediate and
lasting pain.
Plus it allows chafing!
I have scars from chafing so badly on a run
that I started to bleed.
Cute, I know.
But making exercise more comfortable for the
girls goes beyond a good bra -- it means confronting
the embarrassment that we feel about our bodies
and the way they move.
For me, this was just a HUUUUGE deterrent
when I was young.
I was also really upset by the way that guys
ogled at me in gym class or on the street,
sometimes even shouting explicit comments
about my chest.
I didn't want their attention - I just wanted
to exercise.
So, for all my boobly friends out there: TRANSCEND
THE BOOBLINESS.
Don't let your boobs inhibit you(!) - whether
by way of sports bras or insecurity or terrible
people you'll come across.
Save up, have a proper fitting, and invest
in a good bra.
Or as I like to call it: my slingshot.
It's something you deserve!
As for that embarrassment, it helps me to
remember that boobs are: boobs!
Deep, I know.
But really: they're part of being female.
That's a biological fact.
I mean, we all have them to one degree or
another -- sometimes to a really great degree--
and they're nothing to be ashamed of.
If anything, the world should be ashamed for
making others feel bad about their body parts
and for being disrespectful.
So....the world should like....stop that.
Asap.
Thanks for joining me for DNews everyone,
we'll see you next time. ;)